Hi, this is Victor again and
this time I'd like to show you how I
use a screen reader on everyday basis.
In this particular case I will be
using one of my daily things and
that is looking at a public forum that
talks about accessibility issues for
the Android operating system.
>> Open location… About:
blank contents selected,
Address and search bar, edit text
>> You will notice that my screen reader
speaks really fast.
As a beginner user you tend to
listen at much lower speeds.
But as you gain efficiency with the
screen reader, you will find that making
it speak faster improves efficiency
when browsing content on websites.
So back to my public form.
I'm going to go to groups website.
>> [SOUND]
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Since I use this website every day I
know that it provides a lot of shortcut
keys That allowed me to browse this
website much faster.
So first I'll go to my groups.
>> My groups, Google groups,
HTML content.
>> And now I will be using a screen
reader functionality there allows me to
browse through the links on this webpage
because I'd like to find a specific
public forum I'm looking for.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Here
you will see I have
a few message threads.
And quite recently I heard about
this new app called Swift.
It's a braille Keyboard that allows
people who are blind to type braille
faster on Android.
So I'm going to go back to
this thread and look at some
of the messages that I may have missed.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Looking at messages that
I included in this thread.
I used again, shortcut keys to
quickly move through messages.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
I did a 10:32
AM (53 minutes ago) Star this post.
Sergio Brunetti Hi all, sorry.
I am trying to create a new topic.
I sent a message in a wrong place.
I hope now it will work.
Group item.
>> Okay, this gives me some idea as to
what people may have responded since
the last time I looked at this thread.
So I'm going to go back and see-
>> Star this topic, discussion.
>> If there is anything new since
the last time I looked at this forum.
>> Star this topic, discussion.
Will Talkback work on anything
that's running Adroid?
(5).
>> Yeah, there's quite a bit to read.
But anyway I hope this gives you
a quick glance into how I use this view
to an everyday basis.